comment rendre hommage un enfant de 8
ans trois jours après le décès du jeune
lucas le quartier est encore consterné
un enfant de 8 ans on ne mérite pas de
partir on dit toujours que ça aux
parents de partir avant les enfants
c'est partout qu'il était adorable
dignité paul il était gentil souriant
souriant c'était le copain de nos
enfants décédés dans la nuit de dimanche
à lundi
morte par suffocation seule certitude à
ce stade de l'enquêté
quant aux circonstances la version de la
mère celle du cambriolage est
sérieusement remise en doute de très
nombreuses questions subsistent dans la
bouche des parents et dans celle de
leurs enfants surtout pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi c'est pas qu'on répond
bien mais on n'a pas les mots qu'il faut
c'est s'aider geste inexplicable on
n'arrive pas donné les explications
femmes - laurent est un voisin proche
son fils était le meilleur ami du petit
garçon quand il va voir la maison ça va
être dur je sais pas comment je sais pas
j'ai pas comment on va faire
q chaos quoi il n'ya pas d'autres mots
on comprend pas normal on n'est pas bien
on l'attend vraiment le bal
le dénouement moi c'est ce que je veux
l'enquète s'était porté sur la maman de
lucas libéré ce matin elle était en
garde à vue depuis lundi après midi son
témoignage ne collait pas aux premières
constatations
hors de cause pour l'instant les relevés
doivent encore livré leurs secrets
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
par le parquet de chalon